hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome from the
edition of ask Evan today mention a
question from one of my youtube viewers
David who took issue with something I
said in one of my old videos so I was a
profile that I had and one of the things
that I and was that you have to be
unique if you want to be a successful
entrepreneur in saying the information
is useful and inspirational I have a
question regarding one of your action
items personally I don't buy things
because they're unique I'm not aware of
others being inspired to buy things
based on their uniqueness seems to me
that usefulness availability quality
quality affordable affordable price are
way more important than being unique so
thanks for the question David a great
point I think what I would say to that
is I agree people are not going to buy
something just because it's different it
has to add a lot of value and what I
would think about the uniqueness is not
necessarily uniqueness in your product
or service but in your entire business
so all the things that you talked about
here availability quality affordable
price usefulness that could be a way for
your business to be unique right if you
have more availability than anybody else
in this is what helped amazon grow they
have way more ability when they started
than anybody else in a bookstore that
availability made them unique but if
your product or service is way more
useful than somebody else then that
makes your business unique quality again
if you have a super outstanding quality
product compared to everybody else that
makes you unique the pricing is
something that i tend to gear away from
so it can be a point of differentiation
can make your business unique if you
have you know the best price on the
market the challenge here is that's
really hard to sustain in the long term
and you don't want to race to the bottom
you want to try to build up and be able
to provide so much value that you're
able to charge a premium price ideally
that's where I'd like to see you and all
the other entrepreneurs as well it's not
settling for the scraps on the bottom
but I think all the points you mention
are right on exactly true and I see them
as being ways to be unique with your
business my point about being unique is
if you're an average company selling the
average product you know you're not
doing anything special you're not going
to get great results right pick any any
business if you're just selling the same
thing everybody else is selling in the
same way without anything that's
different about it then you're not going
to be able to build a successful
long-term sustainable business you've
got to have something that is different
helps you stand out that is memorable
that makes people want to come back to
you and talk to you if it's not in the
product you being the service it could
be just having the most friendly staff
and you know people who respond very
quickly that could be enough to be
unique for your business you have to
something that people talk about want to
come back to you for you know tell their
friends about and that has to be part of
whatever business you ran and sometimes
it's possible on the product side to
have you know innovations but different
for the sake of different won't help
different and useful is really good
right if you're adding new features to a
product that will really help solve some
of these problem then that can be unique
and really help your business or so
hopefully that helps answer your
question I absolutely agree with what
you're saying because of you watching if
you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below which always makes me
want to do more of these videos for you
and if you have a question about you
know being unique or anything else about
your business feel free to leave it in
the comments below I always read those
and try to respond as quickly as I can
so thank you and you'll see you in the
next episode
you